(pulsing)
- [Zac] Previously.
- [Anderson] On Bro-Dependent.
- [Photographer] Yes, that's yummy!
- Zac!
- Hey!
- Something huge happened.
- Cool story!
- Get them off of my set.
- Click.
(laughs)
- Fuck you guys.
- [Man] That was funny as fuck, dude.
- Yeah, dude, thanks.
- Hey, do you like sex?
- You wanna get into
bed with Quatro Cotton?
- I'd rather just be business partners.
Dude, this commercial shoot
is like, legit as fuck, dude.
Nice production skills.
- Oh, thank you, dude!
- Hey also, it says this shit
has a secret sauce in it,
what is that?
- Oh, okay right,
so I wanted to use like a
human growth hormone in it,
but I guess you can't just buy that,
so I used a little bit of my spooge.
- Oh!
(slurps)
Nice, dude, you can't
even taste it at all!
- So what do you say,
you're ready to, like, act?
- Fuck yeah dude, let's do it!
- Let's do it!
Let's make some magic, fuckfaces!
- Quatro Cotton, take one.
(claps)
- And fucking go!
- Hey Zac.
I heard you were able to
have sex with your girlfriend
two times in a row!
How?
- Easy, Quatro Cotton.
- Thanks.
- Hey, I said I have a girlfriend.
Hey, what's up?
I'm Zac Michaels, star of
daytime TV's Passions Palace.
When I'm participating in a fuck marathon,
and/or doing anything else,
I always drink Quatro Cotton.
What's in it, you ask?
Easy, it's got Quatro energizing compound,
specially formulated
to get your shit right.
Energy drink, secret sauce,
the can, and OxyContin.
- Give me your wallet!
- No!
Hya, hya!
That was close.
Thanks, Quatro Cotton.
Much like steroids, Quatro Cotton--
(phone rings)
Oh wait, shit, hold on.
- Ugh!
Fucking cut, what the fuck, dude?
Zac, hello, that was the one!
- Relax your taint, Spielberg,
it might be a text from Caroline.
It's just like a photo
of some dude's dong.
Whose dong is that?
- Hi, some of the crew is
getting kind of hungry,
so we should--
- Okay, then can you tell them
to go eat a dick?
- Oops.
What the fuck does oops mean?
- I don't know dude, she was probably
sucking some guy's dick,
and then she accidentally
sent a text of it to you.
- Anderson, shut the fuck up,
you know you can't suck a dong
and send a photo at the same time.
- Can we please just do another take,
we're losing the light.
- Fine, where's my fucking robe?
Huh?
- Where's his fucking robe, fuckfaces?
Ah, what the fuck is that, dude?
- [Zac] What?
- [Anderson] That!
- Oh yeah, it's the sweet
tat I got of Caroline's face
over my fucking ripped-ass lats.
I wish I could see it more, though.
- Oh, it really looks like her face.
- Yeah, we're like forever.
Oh, you know what else is forever?
- What?
- Diamonds, bitch.
- Who is that ring for?
- It's for Caroline, you fucknut.
(phone rings)
It's another photo of a dong.
This one's a black dong.
The fuck is wrong with her phone?
- She's fucking other guys!
- I'm fucking warning you, dude.
- Zac, open your eyes, dude!
You're just like this dumb
little fly in her web of vagina.
- I said fucking stop!
- Ow!
Please, dude, I'm trying to protect you,
she doesn't care about you!
- Wow.
Fuck this, I'm out.
- What?
- No, dude, stop.
- That's our thing, don't
do that, stop it, man!
- What?
- Stop doing that!
Zac, please!
- What?
- Fuck, dude!
- Hey!
- Oh, hey.
- What's up?
My roommates and I used to get oxy
from my friend Chloe's boyfriend, but,
then he OD'd.
(chuckles)
- What a pussy.
What's your point?
- Anyway, do you think I could buy some?
- Oh my God, yeah!
Yeah!
Totally, I'll put some
cans in like a box for you,
that's awesome.
- Actually, can I just get the oxy?
- No, I'm not a drug dealer.
- Yeah, but, doesn't that
drink have your cum in it?
- Fine, fine, that's fine.
Thank you.
Just sort of keep this on the down low,
but also, like, tell all
your friends, alright?
- Yeah.
- Okay, great.
And just take one of these,
okay, I'll just feel better.
Great, nice.
I'm a small business owner.
I am a...
The fuck, she gave me like three bucks!
What the, what the fuck?
(upbeat electronic music)
- Hey, thanks for watching Bro-Dependent,
don't forget to comment and
subscribe ComedyCentral.com,
on a serious note, though, you guys,
like, OxyContin and energy drinks
are a diabolical combination, like,
every year, millions of
Americans succumb to headaches
and other, like, malaise and
tiredness-related activities,
so just like, be aware.